after the big win in virginia on tuesday
you may have thought the week couldn't
get any better but you would be wrong as
the last few days have seen the collapse
of not one
not two
but four major fake news narratives
pushed by the left over the past few
years beginning
with good old dr fauci
gain of function
is a very nebulous term
we have spent not us but outside bodies
a considerable amount of effort
to give a more precise definition to the
type
of research that is of concern
that might lead to a dangerous situation
you are aware of that
that is called p3co
we're aware that you deleted gain of
function from the nih website well i can
get back to that a moment if we have
time
but let's get back to the operating
framework and guidewells of which we
operate
under
and you have ignored them
the guidelines are very very clear
eco-health alliance took the virus
and combined it with wiv-1 and caused a
recombinant virus that doesn't exist in
nature and it made my sicker mice that
had humanized cells you're saying that
that's not gain of function research
according to the framework and
guidelines so what you're doing is
defining a weigh gain of function you're
simply saying it doesn't exist because
you changed the definition on the nih
website no no senator paul that's not
gain of function research that is
that is a function gaining inquiry
they're very very different okay and
basically gain and function research is
whatever i don't do okay that's and that
would be bad okay but uh but function
uh increasing uh line of questioning
that uh that's what i did and that's
totally fine rand paul's got fouchy dead
to rights so dr fauci retreats to the
oldest left-wing trick in the book he
tries to redefine the words to redefine
the reality and unfortunately for the
exalted doctor the strategy does not
seem to be working meanwhile
the stories we've been told about kyle
rittenhouse and the blm riots the steele
dossier and russia gate
and critical race theory all are
collapsing this week too because in the
long run no matter how well crafted the
lie
the truth will prevail at least in the
end i'm michael knowles is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from bld
who says
i've died on a thousand hills a thousand
times
and yet i live this is so true when the
libs tell us what you want to die on
this hill
you know whenever you oppose the libs
they say what you're going to are you
really this is the hill you're going to
die on first of all no i have no
intention of dying on any hills but yes
i am going to take a stand on
on a hill or two because if i don't i'm
going to run out of hills to fight on
and when you're out there standing
strong and fighting firm it's important
to look good it's important to dress
well which is why i would really
recommend you check out
nizen and maine i love mizzen and maine
i love missing in maine primarily
because it makes me look really really
cool they're shirts they're oxford
shirts they're polo shirts make me look
really really cool and sleek and hip and
cool
but there's another layer here which is
they combine the comfort and flexibility
of your favorite athletic wear with the
fit and style of a custom dress shirt
lightweight breathable moisture wicking
i am of italian extraction we perspire a
little bit okay this is not great with
some other dress shirts and some other
polos with mizzen and main
not a problem at all i don't need to
worry about that kind of thing the dress
shirts are also machine washable so you
can skip the trips to the dry cleaner
think of all the time think of all the
money you'll say they've got thirty
thousand five star reviews you know they
make a great product i i love them i
love them whether you're updating your
wardrobe to head back to the office or
just looking for a new fault flannel
we've got really good news right now if
you go to
mizzenandmain.com use promo code knowles
you'll get 35 off any regular price
order of 125 bucks or more 35 off when
you go to
m-i-z-z-e-n-a-n-d-m-a-i-n.com use promo
code knowles fauci is embarrassing
himself at this point fauci i always
would at least give him credit for being
a slick politician who was able to pull
a fast one and move the goal posts and
people either did not notice or they let
him get away with it but this is really
embarrassing he perjured himself
months ago to rand paul
and and said that we are not funding
gain of function research we're
certainly not funding it in wuhan but
we're not funding it at all and then it
turns out they were funding and they
were funding it in wuhan and so now dr
fauci is deleting the gain of function
definition from the nih website and he's
trying to to weasel his way out of it
and it's pathetic it's just falling
apart i don't think people buy that
anymore but beyond fouchy beyond
coronavirus look at the case look at the
trial that's going on this week the
trial of kyle rittenhouse
you remember kyle rittenhouse during the
blm riots as the left was torching the
country and killing people and setting
things on fire and we were told it was
all mostly peaceful there was a young
man kyle rittenhouse who
was armed he was protecting himself but
he was he was going just trying to clean
up the neighborhood trying to help the
shop he was working at and some
left-wing
terrorists were coming after him and
kyle rittenhouse shot them quite
apparently in self-defense so now
because kyle rittenhouse is a right
winger and the
people who were chasing him
and threatening him were left-wingers
the left is trying to portray him as a
murderer they're trying to throw him
away for a long time
so the trial's underway
and it's really not going well for the
prosecution because regardless of what
the media told us regardless of the
narrative that they were spinning
even the witnesses that the prosecution
is calling
are
ultimately defending written house
i mean you have no idea
what mr rosenbaum was ever thinking at
any point in his life you have never
been inside his head you never met him
before you don't i've never even i've
never exchanged words with him if that's
what your question is
so your interpretation of what he was
trying to do or what he was intending to
do or anything along those lines is
complete guesswork isn't it um
well he said you and then he reached for
the weapon
rosenbaum is one of these guys that
ridden house killed and uh in apparently
in self-defense so you have no idea you
don't know maybe he
maybe he was reaching for his weapon to
give it to kyle rittenhouse as an early
birthday present maybe when he said fu
maybe that was just his love language
maybe that was just his how do you have
no idea you can't get in the mind of
another person
uh yeah well he screamed fu and reached
for his weapon so you know i don't know
that's i'm not i'm no sherlock holmes
here
but something tells me he wasn't trying
to wish me a happy birthday
another witness the prosecution grilling
this witness the facts really not
looking good for
the left
i stepped in and told everybody chill
out calm down stop doing that
i turned and had an exchange with one of
the protesters
and
i kind of explained to that protester
hey
you know i get it get what you're trying
to do but like not this
and when i turned around
was right there in front of my face
yelling and screaming
and
i would say dude back up just chill
i don't know what your problem is and he
goes you know what if i catch any of you
guys alone tonight i'm gonna kill you
and he said that to you correct
did he say that to the defendant as well
the defendant was there
so yes
oh my gosh
uh look i think
from the facts that we know it's been
clear from the earliest stages of this
that kyle rittenhouse was acting in
self-defense he certainly should not be
convicted of any crime and this this is
basically a witch hunt
uh
but
if the state is going to prosecute this
i think they need a better lawyer
this guy or maybe it's just the case
that all the facts
are on the side of the right here and
they're on the side of kyle rittenhouse
and
they're against the media and the
leftists and the government but i repeat
myself
the guy
said to their faces if i catch you alone
tonight i'm going to kill you
is there any clearer justification for
acting in self-defense probably not
the narrative
the left-wing narrative can last for a
very long time
i don't mean to downplay it
but eventually eventually
the truth is going to peak out okay it's
going to sneak out there we're seeing
this not just with written house but
with
the russia hoax
so there was a big development in the
russia hoax yesterday which is why
you're probably not hearing about it
very much in the media is because they
want to cover it up igor danchensko
was just arrested
indicted by john durham who was leading
the investigation of the origins of the
russia hoax
and arrested igor danchenko
who is igor danchenko
he was the sub source he was one of the
main
sources for
the steele dossier
the steele dossier was the fake dossier
compiled by british spook christopher
steele that was used as the excuse
to let the obama administration spy on
the trump campaign and it's what set the
stage for the trump impeachment and it's
what set the stage for undermining
the entire trump administration
practically
got the it got the fisa warrant to use
against carter page which was just a way
of bugging the trump campaign
doc who funded the dossier hillary
clinton funded the dossier
the dnc
and this guy igor d'anchenko just got
just got arrested why
he got arrested for misleading the fbi
about his relationship with
a major democrat operative who was
working for hillary clinton
he also fabricated the details of a
phone conversation with someone who he
said had a
a well-developed conspiracy of
cooperation knew about a well-developed
conspiracy of cooperation between the
trump campaign and russia
meaning
he lied to the fbi about the whole thing
which was a hoax it was a setup it was
an op
and it's unclear exactly how much of it
was set up by the obama administration
and exactly how much of it was set up by
the dnc and hillary clinton
there's very possibly some combination
of the two
but
this was a hoax
and a setup and even now years and years
later after trump is out of office at
least for now
the truth is coming out
okay and for years that you remember for
years and years it's mueller time
trump he's a putin stooge
he's a traitor
you're any all of you who support him or
are insurrectionist traders selling out
your country to vladimir putin it was
all a complete not just a lie it was a
complete op it was a political operation
by the very democrats
who were pushing it they got away with
it for now by the way they got a trump's
out of office right so they did they did
get away with it it's it's
a slight consolation that at least maybe
someone will go to jail maybe
but politically speaking
they got away with it
people need to be fired over this sort
of stuff and when people get fired you
need to replace them and when you need
to replace them i would recommend zip
recruiter when you have a job opening
you want the best candidates the most
important investment that your company
is going to make okay you want the ideal
candidate
well
what if you could pick your ideal
candidate before they even apply that's
where zip recruiters invite to apply
comes in it gives you the hiring manager
the power to pick your favorites from
top candidates right now you can try it
for free at ziprecruiter.com
knowlescanawles how does invite to apply
work well when you post a job on zip
recruiter they send you the most
qualified people for your job then you
can easily review the candidates and
invite your top choices to apply for
your job it's just so
high tech so cool so easy and it will
really help you make sure that when
you're looking at the best investments
most important ones you can make in your
company you're making the right choice
see for yourself go to zip recruiter dot
com slash knowles canon wlis that's
ziprecruiter.com knowles to try zip
recruiter for free
ziprecruiter the smartest way to hire
you got
hoaxes falling apart from dr fauci
from
the blm people over kyle rittenhouse
from the russia hoax people over the
steele dossier
but there's a hoax going on right now
okay there's a there's a hoax that the
left is trying to perpetrate right now
they are trying to convince everyone
that critical race theory is not being
taught in schools what you're what you
are being told right now is that
critical race well for a while they were
telling you critical race theory is
awesome and we need to have it in every
school but then they realized that
wasn't a good strategy so they said no
critical race theory uh-uh it's it's
only being taught in harvard law school
you idiots you rubes you probably
haven't even read kimberly crenshaw no
critical race theory
is not being taught in schools and the
republicans are lying to you about it
and they're doing it because they're
racists and they don't want to teach you
about slavery or what whatever right
so
an administrator at the largest school
district in indiana has just released a
video it's a really
terrific
concise description
of how the left
is in fact teaching critical race theory
in schools
i'm the science coach in admin in the
largest public school district in
indiana i'm in dozens of classrooms a
week so i see exactly what we're
teaching our students when we tell you
that schools aren't teaching critical
race theory that it's nowhere in our
standards that's misdirection we don't
have the quotes and theories as state
standards per se we do have critical
race theory in how we teach we tell our
teachers to treat students differently
based on color we tell our students that
every problem is a result of white men
and that everything western civilization
built is racist capitalism as a tool of
white supremacy those are straight out
of kimberly crenshaw's main points
verbatim in critical race theory the
writings that formed the movement this
is in math history science english the
arts and it's not slowing down if
students of color have lower reading
scores it's because of inequity
therefore we take from the white
students and give to the color students
that's richard delgado straight out of
crt in introduction
all teaching is political with reality
and facts taking the back seat that's dr
gloria lads and billings who outlined
how she saw critical race theory flushed
out in public schools in 1995.
when schools tell you that we aren't
teaching critical race theory it means
one thing go away and look into our
affairs no further
no no but it's not critical race theory
it's um
it's inquisitive
ethnicity idea
yeah no we're so we're not we're
teaching we're not teaching critical
race theory we're teaching all the
tenets of critical race theory like that
we need to abolish whiteness and that
america is hopelessly uh irredeemably
bigoted and racist because of white
supremacy and this pervades even the
economic system which is hopelessly
unjust which is why we need to to end
free enterprise and and uh enact some
form of socialism and it's why we need
to radically upend our system of
government so yeah it's all the
critical race theory stuff but it's not
but that it's not called we don't call
it critical race theory anymore what
they're doing it's the same thing
dr fauci tried to do to rand paul
they're just trying to redefine reality
by
redefining all the words it's it's a
retreat into to use the technical term
nominalism to say oh
what does that name even mean oh who
what what really is critical race theory
it's the thing you're teaching that's
what
that's what critical race theory is so
what's the answer to all of this you're
seeing an answer right now
in texas
and it's going to make some of the
squishes a little uncomfortable
but it's the right answer nonetheless
you know let me see i think i have an
article somewhere yes so this is how npr
is is portraying this in texas headline
a texas lawmaker
is targeting 850 books
that he says could make students feel
uneasy oh you know what he i bet he's a
book banner a book burner
who is just trying to protect the
feelings of the white evil people and
he's ignoring the truth and we can't ban
books and we how dare you
it's not exactly what's going on here
but this is this is really good stuff
the uh the lawmaker's name is matt kraus
matt grouse has a list of books that
ought to be that he believes ought to be
investigated and potentially removed
from curricula at schools because
they're filling students heads with a
bunch of crap
texas governor greg abbott is now
getting behind this
movement what is really going on here is
this
is this banning books is this regressive
sort of well
i guess in a way it is kind of banning
books okay and i know that on the right
in recent years we've adopted this
attitude that it's we should never ban
books we should know we should just have
all the books they should we should have
if it includes hardcore porn in schools
we should just have all the books right
but
uh no i don't think we should
i really don't think we should first of
all
every political community
has limits even on books
some people every political commercial
community
throughout history has at some point
burned books okay not even just ban them
but burn them
and some of the people who have burned
books
have been perfectly wise and right to do
so do you know uh plato would be an
example of someone who burned books
he he advocated burning the books of one
of his
philosophical rivals
um
the apostles in in the acts of the
apostles in the bible you see burning
books burning sorcery books when the
christians come in and evangelize this
is portrayed and it's portrayed as a
very good thing i don't particularly
care for martin luther martin luther you
know what he did he burned books
so it's not just the old terrible
back-minded catholics the protestants
have burned books the pagans have burned
books
the liberals burn and ban books
they're we we currently ban
books in school at least one book
and and it's been pushed by the liberty
what is the one book that we ban in
schools right now
it's an obvious answer but we don't
think about it
the bible
that's the book that's the one book you
can't be taught in schools
because of a ridiculous supreme court
decision pushed by the left
so i hope the left spares me their pearl
clutching over the idea that we're going
to kick certain books out of the
curriculum yes we are going to kick
ibram candy's idiotic nonsense out of
the curriculum if we can yes we are
going to kick rob and deangelo's race
hustling idiocy out of the classroom
okay frankly i think we ought to put the
bible back in the classroom the bible
the most important book ever written
the the font of all wisdom all of all of
western thought and literature
that we're not allowed to teach
but the idiotic ravings of tony heasy
codes that we have to teach that would
be an affront to liberal education if we
got written give me
a break it's so disingenuous
okay
there's only so many weeks in the
semester there's only so many books that
you can read okay and so
the purpose of education to make us free
is uh requires that we
read the best books the books that are
best going to help us understand the
world cultivate
our our deepest resources and uh
bring our base passions into accord with
our rational will okay and so you're
going to be able to do that by reading
the classics by reading serious works
and you're not going you're actually
going to undermine that by reading porn
and by filling your head with lies and
propaganda like howard zen like
robin deangelo like ibrahim kennedy and
so those books should be kicked out of
the curriculum there is nothing
hypocritical there is nothing dangerous
there's nothing illiberal even about
that
the left has been doing it for a very
long time there are plenty of reasons to
circumscribe books and it's it's about
it's long past time that conservatives
started taking a stand in this arena as
well now there is some confusion on this
because the the right has adopted a lot
of the language of
the left and i'm afraid that even
winsome sears the newly elected
lieutenant governor of virginia is doing
this a little bit as well i really like
what little i know about wins winsome
sears
she is she's really having a moment
right now on the internet because her
social media team is is
pretty strong so they're they're calling
her based and they're doing meme
contests and they're sending photos of
her just holding like a giant gun and
she just seems great uh however she said
something that
is not true and so though i like her a
lot this is coming from a place of love
it's mostly directed at her speech
writers and her social media director
she tweeted out quote let's teach our
children how to think not what to think
and this is a line that countless
right-wingers have used in recent years
and it's a nonsensical phrase it doesn't
mean anything i know people think it
means something but it doesn't because
it is not possible to teach someone how
to think without also teaching someone
what to think
it is not possible to teach someone how
to think about english history without
teaching them that
the battle of hastings took place in
1066. you need to teach them that and if
if the student says it was 1065
then you got to punish them you got to
mark them wrong you got to give them a
low grade you have to teach them what to
think in order to know how to think
about certain if you don't teach someone
that two plus two equals four
you cannot teach them how to think
about mathematics this is true in ethics
and morality too if you don't teach
someone that it is wrong to murder you
can't teach someone how to think about
morality
the the
very very
hippy-dippy left-wing notion
that we should just teach people to come
to their own conclusions about every
single thing no matter what the answer
is is preposterous
well i taught my student how to think
and now he thinks that it's good to
commit murder but it's he came to the
decision he did it himself no he got it
wrong he he learned how to think the
wrong way
because he learned
the things he learned what to think were
not true
okay and we need to get a little tougher
about that and it we're not gonna sound
really liberal and hippy-dippy and nice
and open-minded and everything we're
gonna we're gonna sound in a way a
little bit closed-minded but you need to
sometimes you need to be a little closed
minded skepticism has utility only when
it leads to conviction
all right we got to put limits on our
gas prices these days too it's going
through the roof which is why you got to
check out
get upside christmas has come early for
you
you are welcome it is my pleasure to
bring to you the timeliest
advertiser maybe that we've ever had get
upside
right now my listeners are making up to
25 cents on every single gallon of gas
every single time they fill up download
the the free get upside app in the app
store or google play right now use promo
code knowles know wles get a bonus 25
cents per gallon on your first fill up
that is up to 50 cents cash back do not
pay full price at the pump anymore get
cash back using get upside just download
the app for free use promo code knowles
kwles to get up to 50 cents per gallon
cashback on your first tank some people
who drive a lot are making as much as
two to three hundred dollars per month
cash back there's no catch the cash gets
added right to your bank account or to
paypal or to an e-gift card for amazon
or wherever wherever you want other than
that it's so easy just download the free
get upside app use promo code knowles
canon wles to get up to 50 cents per
gallon cashback on your first tank code
knowles
just a little cherry on top of the
sunday of this wonderful week
there was a race in new jersey for a
state rep race right
and the state rep race no one was really
paying attention to it because it had
the top
democrat lawmaker in new jersey
a guy by the name of steve sweeney and
so he was super powerful he was that no
one was going to really challenge him
and so there was just this guy this
republican truck driver named edward
durr
he spent
153 on his campaign quite a lot of it on
donuts
it's not a joke
and so it's going to be a throwaway
whatever you know we'll get them next
time
and then the truck driver won
the top democrat went down
and this guy edward durr who spent
dollars on his campaign he won
now look i don't
i don't know anything about edward durr
i i hope he's a good
candidate i love that he beat the
democrat i hope he he
is a good
politician and i hope he learns to
become a good politician and he's got i
i just i really don't know nobody really
knows a lot about him right now
but i love the victory and i love the
victory because
what it shows is
people
are really sick
of this ruling class
okay and they just
they want anything but this ruling class
and it shows that we can at least
sometimes
boot this ruling class
out of power
the vote for edward durr look he might
be the greatest candidate in the world
but the fact that you've got such a
low funded sort of unknown candidate
comes in and beats the top democrat
that's probably more of a protest vote
it's a protest vote against something
and even in new jersey even in blue new
jersey that's a great sign
ron desantis is showing this in florida
ron desantis you know he's a very
talented politician and he's very good
at using applause lines and
but take a listen to this applause line
that he just used at an event down in
florida
this uh
this shows you a little bit of a shift
in the focus
for the the republicans this year and
going into 2022 and 2024.
sometimes people will ask me oh man how
come florida 84 000 jobs the rest of the
country you know what what could be done
to help the rest of the country and i
say well you know the saying that i
always think back and it's a little bit
of a flourish on how it's been used
previously
but a recession is when your neighbor
loses his job a depression is when you
lose yours a recovery is when dr fauci
loses his
yeah now this is an old formulation you
know a recession is this a recovery is
this an er a depression recession is
this a depression is this and recovery
is this ronald reagan made great use of
it many decades ago talking about jimmy
carter a recession
is when your neighbor loses his job
a depression is when you lose yours
and recovery
is when jimmy carter loses his
great line i've used the line myself but
but
notice the shift here
in the 80s it's ronald reagan
using the line against the elected
president jimmy carter
today
we're using the line against some
bureaucrat dr fauci
in the 80s
the chief political opponent was the
democrat party
today the chief political opponent
is the blob
it's the ruling class the deep state the
permanent government call it whatever
you want
it seems like a subtle shift that's a
major shift
it shows you where the power has moved
in the country
and what people are rebelling against
right now is not joe biden if ron
desantis had used that line against joe
biden it would have probably fallen flat
yeah we don't like biden we joke about
him let's go brandon hahaha but no one
thinks the guy is with it no one thinks
the guy is really pulling the strings
someone like fauci though he's been
around for what seven presidents now
highest paid employee in the federal
government
he's the problem
it's a it's a regime issue not so much a
partisan issue speaking of this ruling
class there was one of the creepiest
corporate presentations i've ever seen
in my life just came out from microsoft
listen to how these
software spokesmen begin their
presentation
hello and welcome to microsoft ignite
we've got a big day ahead and lots in
store for you
first we want to acknowledge that the
land where the microsoft campus is
situated was traditionally occupied by
the sammamish the duwamish the
snoqualmie the suqamish the mukulshut
the snohomish the tulalip and other
coast salish peoples since time
immemorial a people that are still here
continuing to honor and bring to light
their ancient heritage
my name is allison wines i'm a senior
program manager in our developer tools
division i'm an asian white female with
dark brown hair wearing a red sleeveless
top
and i'm seth juarez program manager in
the ai platform group i'm a tall
hispanic male wearing a blue shirt khaki
pants today we kick off two days of
learning more about the latest solutions
exploring how these key innovations can
empower you to do great things and
connecting with peers from around the
world
huh
what what was that
first okay let's take it backwards
forward
from the end to the beginning they say
i'm an asian lady and i'm a sort of
white guy and i
why do i care why do i care about your
race and you're talking about the
clothing you're wearing oh it's for
i think it's for blind people
i think they're doing this for blind
people because identity politics doesn't
work for blind people because they can't
see and they genuinely don't they
literally don't see color but that
doesn't work for the left because the
left needs to make every single thing
about race and these kind of physical
attributes of identity and so they've
actually got to tell you be like hey hey
hey i'm a black guy treat me differently
hey i know you can't see me and you
don't care but i am
you should treat me differently based on
my race okay and they open up they say
we're here on the land of the shumatami
muskatuzy people and then it goes on
this whole list who cares
when i go to the bronx i do not often
hear you know the puerto rican guy in
the bronx say hi i'm a puerto rican guy
wearing you know jeans and a t-shirt and
i am acknowledging that i'm standing on
land that was once inherited by black
guys and before that by sicilian guys
and before that by the irish and before
that okay what do i care
you're in america you're standing on
you're standing on the microsoft campus
land now run by microsoft but it's this
it has to be this constant preening sort
of guilt by the way i don't think this
little
acknowledgement makes the musketeers
feel any better that they lost their
land hundreds of years ago let's move on
buddy this is this is the world that's
how this is how the world works it's so
the reason i even bring it up
is to show though this is not about
this is not about
the government big government you know
one of the big
unfortunate events that came after the
the big virginia win is that the
establishment republicans tried to make
this all about socialism it's all just a
rejection of social socialism did not
play a single role in the virginia
election
okay it was about
culture it was about critical race
theory it was about transgender ideology
in schools it was it's not even just
about the government it's about micros i
don't want my corporations pushing this
crap and upending my traditions and my
society and
ripping america apart at the seams and
so if it's the government doing that
then let's go after the government if
it's corporations i'm happy to go after
the corporations too and that's a big
difference between the the impotent
talking points of the republican party
for the past
20 years
and what's going on today as you may or
may not be aware
the daily wire filed a lawsuit against
the federal government yesterday
why because
the biden administration the the
anti-american biden administration
ordered that large employers must
require their employees to be vaccinated
against the wu flu or submit to regular
testing the daily wires lawsuit was
filed by the dillon law group
and alliance defending freedom in the
sixth circuit court of appeals the
lawsuit alleges that the biden
administration lacks constitutional and
statutory authority to issue the
employer mandate and that the mandate
failed to meet the requirements for
issuing a rule taking effect immediately
without the normal process of
considering public comments this mandate
is unconstitutional we are not standing
for it here at the daily wire our
employees deserve to keep their medical
history private have some control over
their own bodies and honor any of their
religious beliefs and there are plenty
of reasons not to take this vaccine
moral and prudential
we stand with our employees rights we do
do this also with the rights of every
single american the biden administration
has warned that any companies that do
not comply with this federal overreach
could be fined as much as 136
thousand dollars
per violation
per violation
no company really can withstand this in
the long run this is why we need your
help if you are not a member yet please
consider joining us today if you go to
dailywire.com subscribe enter code do
not comply at checkout you'll receive 25
off your membership you will be fighting
this unconstitutional mandate with us
we appreciate your help and we will not
comply we'll be right back with the
mailbag
welcome back to my favorite time of the
week the mailbag first question up from
vincent michael i have a situation in
which i require some advice
i am in my college play and i believe
that the costume designer is a girl who
says she is a boy i have not confirmed
this but if this is the case how should
i talk about this person in their
presence
and in the rest of the cast's presence
should i make my position known or
should i stay silent so as to not
alienate anyone as the show is in
a week i appreciate any advice you give
and thanks well you know you don't know
i mean this this gets back to the old um
the old snl gag
about pat
some people are just sort of
sexually ambiguous and you're doing this
like it's pat that's like is pat a boy
or his pet a girl i don't know in some
people so you don't you don't want to
insult this person who you said it's a
girl who's pretending to be a boy so
you you don't want to be in a position
where you
make a big issue out of this and then
someone's not even trying to make a an
ideological point it's just a girl who
seems kind of
tomboy-ish or a boy who's kind of
femmy you know
or whatever you know you don't want to
do that certainly i wouldn't i wouldn't
buy into the transgender ideology the
the good thing you have going for you
though is that when you are in someone
else's presence and you're talking about
that person it's rude to use their
pronouns
it's just generally rude if you're
standing next to sheila from the office
you go you know what she said to me the
other day you know what you know what
this broad said to me no you would say
sheila made this good point and so i
think that's how you would get around it
i don't know i assume this person has a
sort of
sexually ambiguous name as well you know
tyler or something skyler whatever um
you would probably just use
use the name
if you're in if you're in a theater
community the odds that there's some
sexual confusion going around are about
150 percent so you know i wouldn't be
surprised if that's what's going on but
there are ways to
stand your ground and to not give in to
gender ideology without
without being
necessarily offensive you know without
without going out of your way to do so
and and this is actually the harder
thing to do is
you know rather than showboating i'll
take your situation out of it for a
second let's say you're talking about
bruce jenner and uh
you're talking to someone and someone
refers to she you know she caitlyn
jenner and you say yeah well you know
what bruce said was da da da da da da da
da
you can do it in a way that is quiet and
subtle and confident and not saying he
is not a she he is a he and how dare you
you know you can just
kind of hold your ground firmly quietly
politely that's that's what i would
recommend doing from jim
i asked what the point in a high school
relationship was a week ago
i might be getting into a high school
relationship soon because of your answer
oh yeah because i said i met my wife in
high school
we split for college which i think is
now a statutory requirement for
millennials wish we hadn't wish we'd
gotten married sooner um
but yeah i think high school
relationships can be great so
jim goes on now i have to ask what would
i do in a high school relationship
i'm not very good in these types of
things so i thought i would go to an
expert thanks
this is a family show buddy i don't know
i don't know what you what you want me
to say no i i can i can tell you
when i was a youth
teenage boy
into my early teens
i was
i was an atheist okay
i did not adhere to
catholic
teaching
theology of the body
chastity all the things that you're you
really should be doing and so i behaved
in a way that i would not recommend okay
i but but i think you certainly can have
a relationship as a teenager or in
college or in high school or whatever
that is a very serious relationship and
remains chaste does this mean you can
never hold the girl's hand you can never
kiss the girl you can never go no it
doesn't mean that but it does mean that
you ought to respect certain boundaries
and
our culture is really bad at that i
think a lot of people
i hear this a lot from people like me
who are reverts you know who lived like
atheists for a long time and then
reverted to the faith and they feel or
converted rather
also they feel lied to they feel like
they were told i mean they were
encouraged in
high school and college that you need to
sleep around and and break every sort of
social and sexual convention that
existed even 50 years ago and you need
to just take things and date a million
people and you know swipe right and
swipe right and swipe right and you just
have to do that that's just what the
culture is and you don't
you don't actually you also don't need
to sit at home in your room and never
speak to a girl right that would be the
complete other side but what you can do
is recognize that men and women
are made for each other they're
complimentary we think they're cute you
know we're attracted to these other
people we can express that attraction we
can engage in that
uh while still respecting the other
person and respecting ourselves
moderation actually
is a virtue and chastity is too but have
a good time from andrew hey michael i
hear you speaking about how the problem
with marriage is how we allowed our
society to have gay marriage and thus
redefining what marriage is well it's
not the the problem there are a lot of
problems but uh sure that's part of it i
agree with all this however i think
marriage was ruined from making it a
legal thing in the first place it ruined
its value
it's part of our relationship with god
not people therefore i believe marriage
should be overseen by our religious
institutions and if a church or
synagogue wants to approve a gay
marriage or two two random guys decide
to say they're married they can curious
your thoughts on this thanks love your
show and all that you do i'm afraid
andrew i appreciate the compliment but
i'm afraid
you are wrong about this
marriage
is an oath before god that's true
marriage is also an oath to this other
person your spouse
and marriage is also an oath before the
public
it is a public act it always has been
because marriage is not merely a private
institution but a public institution
this is why divorce was not permitted in
most places in the civilized west
for a very long time
until very very recently actually
you're making an oath you're signing a
contract and it's not just an oath
between two people who can consent to do
whatever they want and if they decide to
break the contract it's totally fine
you're making a vow to society because
marriage is the bedrock political
institution the family is the better
it's the local community the township is
not the the smallest political
institution it's not the basic one the
family is
okay
likewise if if two people decide to say
that their relationship is a marriage
they don't have the right to do that if
the relationship is not a marriage no
more than i have the right to call my
leftist tears tumbler a bicycle
well what's the big deal who's it
hurting if you say that your leftist
year's tumblr is a bicycle well it's
just not true that's the problem
and we don't have the right to
say things that are not true
we have an obligation to pursue the
truth okay and so i but i don't you know
to your point i don't i don't just blame
the gays or something like that the
institution of marriage has been
weakened for many many years no fault
divorce was really the beginning of that
uh at least in
modern times and so
my answer to that is not to weaken
marriage further and read just like dr
fauci did with gain of function research
redefine it into nothingness my answer
to that would be to more clearly define
it say now marriage
marriage does involve sexual difference
and
two fellows who like each other and two
women who like each other that's fine
they can like each other they can have a
relationship but it just is not marriage
and you know no amount of
you know messing around with the words
is going to change that and furthermore
if you are married you can't just get
out of it you can't just break it
willy-nilly because you are fracturing
you're hurting children to do that
you're but you're also fracturing
society and you're undermining our our
trust in one another and our trust in
oaths and
and the very notion of a public oath
itself
to say nothing of your obligation to god
so i would i would say yes marriage is
in a great state of disarray
the answer is not to
make it even more subjective make it
even more personal make it even more
relative the answer is to make it more
objective and clearer from matthew good
day mr knowles
would you please explain the differences
between the philosophies of edmund burke
and john locke thank you under the
omnipotence
matthew
yes
burke
broadly is a conservative
lock broadly is a big lib
that that would be the difference edmund
burke
once said that john locke's second
treatise of government
is
one of the worst books ever written okay
and i know a lot of american
conservatives these days really like
john locke it's kind of a more recent
development that they're really into
john locke but john locke is the father
of liberalism now on that i will say
john locke was way more based than
people give him credit for you know he
did say that we should ostracize
atheists from society and things like
that so he was pretty tough-minded too
but but his
philosophy i'm not going to be able to
do justice to the the great conservative
tradition in the great liberal tradition
right now but
locke's idea of society is just a bunch
of contracts
that therefore can be dissolved
basically at one's whim
and caprice
is ultimately a very liberal idea
the idea that we're you know the basic
unit of society is the individual that's
a very liberal idea
edmund burke's idea and every edinburgh
was a defender of the american
revolution so it's it's not as though he
were just uh
he's completely
unrelatable to the american experience
but edmund burke's idea
is uh no
we are born not primarily with rights
and entitlements but with obligations
with oaths with with duties with with
loyalty
and uh that the bonds of society really
cannot be broken willy-nilly they ought
not to be broken willy-nilly that we
ought to
look to our great tradition and
recognize we have an obligation to the
people who came before us and that there
are higher things than just
personal autonomy
edmund burke refers to that exalted
freedom
which uh
which can ennoble even servitude itself
you know that that uh generous loyalty
to rank and sex i could go on and on
about him all day but basically burke
was right
worth reading locke but
if you're gonna read just those two guys
burke was was more correct from andrew
hello michael as a former new yorker do
you believe that new york city will ever
get back to being a city that is
actually desirable to stay and raise
family in it's too expensive and with
the election of eric adams the democrat
is there any hope of seeing a giuliani
type mayor return should i look into the
right flight
or stick around and hope for the best ps
the vax mandate shut down 26 fire
stations and thousands of cops are
pending exemptions they will probably
get denied thanks to de blasio
yeah i'm a new yorker as you may know
and i did leave new york and i left new
york originally for california and uh
and then
daily wire which was based in california
moved to tennessee and i'm very happy
that i moved to tennessee and i like
going back to visit new york but i think
new york right now
is in the 1970s
could there be a giuliani type yeah i
hope so
i hope so i really love new york and i
think that
new york has a kind of
it has a kind of base level conservatism
that a lot of people who are not new
yorkers don't really get
it's got the conservatism of the italian
immigrants it's got the conservatism of
the cops and the firefighters it's got
the
conservatism of
just being an old place
you know being a tough old place
so
yes there could be some kind of
semi-renewal but
really depends what you want to do
you know if you
if you want to if your family's there
and you want to stay near your family
and you know stay and you love the city
and you just want to go to the places in
the city and really just continue to
build your life there
i think that's all well and good and
just know you're going to have a tough
time
if you want to build and grow a business
if you want to
you know
rally the troops the right-wing troops
and have an effect on national politics
if you want to do that sort of thing
i think you got to leave it's really it
just depends on what you want
from kenneth
hey mike if all the nominations for
science awards are only for white guys
what does this mean when the left says
to follow the science they're actually
saying listen to the white guys
seriously just another white guy as a
slightly off-white guy you know taupe
maybe or bathe beige or whatever you
call
this sort of swarthy skin i would agree
and i think they should follow me i
think it's a good idea i should they
should do that it's true
but they're not you know but in fairness
the story you're referencing where the
science award committee wouldn't give
the award to people because they're
white guys
the logical conclusion of that is that
if a scientist is a white guy then he's
just not really a scientist so you
shouldn't follow him he shouldn't win an
award certainly you shouldn't follow him
from samantha
michael i'm 21 years old i've felt truly
born again by the good book i'm studying
the bible coming closer to god i felt in
my heart i want that i want to be
baptized however my husband does not
share the same enthusiasm he's 23 and
active duty military his relationship
with the army has shaped his
relationship with god this has put us in
a position where i'm waking up every
sunday and pleading with him to come
with me i have about a 50 success rate
of getting him to come with me what
should i do to motivate him to try again
with god and should i
wait on getting baptized until he
supports me thanks no you should get
baptized uh you know but it's a big
change for him
probably you know this has happened with
me you know i've
dated my wife uh long before i was a
practicing christian
um so it can be jarring when people feel
a call to faith so
i'll try to bring him along
ask him you know be
show him the fruits of your faith
certainly i would get baptized
um
at the very least and and you know
recognize that
things happen in god's good time but one
one word of caution here i would not
allow anyone
to get
between your relationship with god okay
that's our show i'm michael noel's the
michael knowles show see you monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin